[Music]
what is it about this show that keeps
you coming back I know obviously you're
the executive producer but Lisa what's
so fun about it for you oh I like this
game and it's fun to play with Courtney
so I mean I got like the added bonus of
and you'll be playing these games with
Courtney okay he was across the way we
look at him after the binocular a naked
ugly guard yeah Roger Steve Burton you
know Shay good but it's pretty good ugly
naked oh yeah
I think someone were thinking they would
put both of these women in a TV show cuz
I think it would work agree I wanted to
do this days ago so I think I should go
first all right that makes sense but
when you look back at Monica Geller and
Phoebe Buffay where do each of you think
that each other's character is today
what are they up to
I haven't thought about that at all I
don't know why me she'd be married of
like Connecticut guy right or they were
like a Upper East Side New York family
Mike yeah you think that Monica would be
up to these days it's probably raising
all of her little kids and she's cooking
and she's with Chandler and they're
happy and he probably got a job you know
it's smoking steroids and putting in the
drawer in some kind of bank or something
I don't know what did he do what was
Chandler you wouldn't know what he did
find out what he'd add this job I don't
think we did because there was that one
gameshow episode where Rachel couldn't
guess it carries a briefcase ten seconds
you need to so you lose the game it was
transponding oh by the transverse trans
monster
Oh Mike yep
she married Mike okay who played like
Paul Rudd that's Mike oh my god of
course sorry you got married Anne yeah
Missouri wedding there was a wedding I
did was I there I don't remember yeah
we're there it was in the snow I can
honestly don't know never you guys got
married outside of Central Perk in the
snow
I don't assert it it okay well
[Music]
you